er hatte schon ein gespräch mit annegret
kramp karrenbauer letzten samstag bei
der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
vor ort waren sie jedoch nicht als cdu
vertreter sondern als
verteidigungsministerin beziehungsweise
außenpolitiker viele themen gab es dort
zu besprechen für die nord cdu
vorsitzende und den neuesten kandidaten
für ihre nachfolge über seine bewerbung
habe er aber auch sie erst heute
informiert
es geht um die zukunft der cdu und es
geht um die christlich demokratische
idee von der zukunft unseres landes
davon habe ich seit der
rückzugsankündigung von annegret kramp
karrenbauer wenig gehört und darum
kandidiere ich in röttgens politkarriere
geht es lange zeit vor allem bergauf
2009 wird der bundesminister für umwelt
ein jahr später setzt er sich in
nordrhein-westfalen im ringen um den
cdu-landesvorsitz durch in einer
mitgliederbefragung gegen armin laschet
doch bei der landtagswahl 2012 verliert
er dann trotz anfänglichen vorsprungs in
den umfragen sport gibt es da selbst aus
der schwesterpartei
der rückgang hat gegen die verkauft mit
einem verhältnis 37 zu 34 begonnen und
innerhalb von sechs wochen ist es weg
geschmolzen wie eisbecher der in der
sonne steht
als er sich dann weigert in nrw die
opposition zu führen wirft merkel ihn
aus dem kabinett
es ist die totale niederlage wenn man so
eine niederlage erlebt hat dann ist das
dann ist das bleibt das relevant aber es
bleibt vor allen dingen relevant wenn
man wieder aufgestanden ist seither er
warf röttgen vor allem außenpolitisches
profil weniger als parteistratege nun
fordert er
die cdu müsse sich klar zur afg aber aus
ganz anderen gründen auch zur linken hat
grenzen
zudem ein ost west dialog auf augenhöhe
fördern
und seine chance nun als vierter
kandidaten sieht er sich nicht
ich bin der bislang erste und einzige
der seine kandidatur erklärt hat ich
habe gelesen dass es überlegungen bei
anderen gibt das aber noch irgendwie
auch gesehen wird wie die taktischen
opportunitäten herzustellen sind
insofern muss ich sagen bin ich nicht
der vierte sondern ich bin der erste der
die kandidatur klar erklärt er hat
übrigens noch keinen neuen
gesprächstermin mit ihr aber es gehe ihm
jetzt auch nicht um kaffee trinken
sondern darum dass der prozess nun
politisch werde paukenschlag also
norbert röttgen l will es wissen und
cdu-parteivorsitzende erwerben und bei
mir ist jetzt unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent mathis feldhoff
guten tag mattes welche chancen hat noch
entgehen ist tatsächlich an die spitze
der zeitung zu schaffen na ja das weiß
ja glaube ich selber und wenn man
ehrlich ist die chancen sind doch eher
gering aber trocken ist ja 2012 damals
nicht nach nrw gegangen als
oppositionsführer das hat ihm die partei
in nrw dass der größte landesverband
aber auch angela merkel sehr
übelgenommen angela merkel hat ihn
damals dann als umweltminister entlassen
und der ist tief gefallen
also sowas vergisst seine partei nicht
dass jemand im grunde wegläuft an seiner
stelle auch wenn er sagt ich bin wieder
aufgestanden
jetzt ist der erste offizielle
prominente bewerber muss man sagen es
gibt ja drei weitere friedrich merz
armin laschet und jens spahn in die sich
wohl auch bewerben werden
in den letzten tagen gab es immer wieder
stimmen die gesagt haben bloß eine
teamlösung keine kampfkandidatur ist das
jetzt obsolet diese ganzen pläne wird
auf eine kampfkandidatur hinauslaufen
es scheint so zu sein er hat gesagt er
ist der kandidat für den parteitag und
wenn er die unterstützung von
entsprechenden kreisverbänden hat kann
er auf dem parteitag antreten das will
er offenbar er hat diese teamlösung als
machtpolitische lösung beschrieben eben
also als zehnter als eine lösung von den
leuten die sich um diese ganzen
inhaltlichen fragen die wir aufgemacht
hat herum drücken wollen
das ist klar eine kampfansage an merz
und laschet oder auch an sparen und dann
hat er einfach gesagt was interessant
war er hat nämlich gesagt dass er das
gefühl hatte seinen letzten jahren die
politik vor allem den vergessen hat mit
den menschen zu reden dass man die
menschen im stich gemacht lassen habe
das habe ihm angst
und das würden sie zur afg treiben und
damit meint er vor allem den angela
merkel also im kern ist dies auch eine
kandidatur gegen angela merkel
ok also röttgen positioniert sich
strategisch wirken wir jetzt nochmal
nach thüringen
da hat die linkspartei ja die cdu in
thüringen in die bredouille gebracht sie
hat der offerte gemacht sie hat gesagt
wir wollen eine übergangs
ministerpräsidentin und die kann von der
cdu christine lieberknecht schlagen wir
vor ist das für die cdu zu schön um wahr
zu sein
sonnigen bitteres dilemma was da jetzt
gerade passiert christine lieberknecht
ist die vorgängerin von herrn ramelow
das ist sozusagen ja das problem das ist
möglicherweise eine kandidatin auch wenn
sie von der cdu kommt die feinen rahmen
noch vorgeschlagen schon zusammenarbeit
mit der cdu mit der linkspartei weiß ich
nicht aber mal im ernst christine
lieberknecht hätte ja genau eine aufgabe
nämlich neuwahlen zu organisieren
das heißt eine von ihnen müsste
neuwahlen organisieren bei denen die cdu
nach allen umfragen die wir jetzt kennen
sich möglicherweise halbieren würde das
ist natürlich ein total bitteres dilemma
und deswegen für dauert solange man die
veilchen den thüringer landtag über die
frage wann dieser wahltermin sein könnte
die cdu würde gern im herbst wählen die
linkspartei deutlich früher bei der aus
machtpolitischem kalkül
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
mathis feldhoff